an arrest warrant was just issued for
dokuan the founder of terra luna a 40
billion cryptocurrency that collapsed to
almost zero earlier this year and i know
what you guys are waiting for let's just
put this guy on the wall of shame and
just be done with him but unfortunately
we can't just yet because the situation
is a bit more complicated than it seems
at first
you see dokwan's arrest warrant was
issued from south korea according to
bloomberg where he's allegedly violated
the nation's capital markets law and if
you don't know what that means here's a
hint the law applies to crypto tokens
that quote work like securities so south
korea seems to be treating this like a
securities law violation which makes
sense most companies can't offer 20 a
year in stable returns and stay out of
jail for very long which is maybe why
dokwan along with five others are now
wanted in south korea however there's a
twist because dokuan
doesn't live in south korea anymore he's
living now in singapore so does this
warrant apply to him i mean sure he
can't go to bts concerts anymore but is
he actually going to get arrested well
it depends on whether south korea can
get dokuan extradited which it seems
like they're going to try to given the
fact that they knew he was in singapore
and filed this anyway they probably
think they have a good shot at it which
given the scale of luna's collapse i do
think they have a chance and i do think
it's also very important for us to at
least try to give consequences to the
people like dokwan who set up these
ridiculous crypto ponzi schemes
otherwise what's the point what's the
lesson of watching luna you know just go
repeat what dokuan did and hurt more
people but yourself make money i mean
that's what justin sun is literally
doing right now with usdd although it's
worth saying that do kwan wouldn't call
himself a winner with luna he claims
he's down infinite
he said it in an interview he did with
coinage media the word that i used to
describe what happened here is down
infinite
i've just got to say there's something
so ridiculous about being interviewed in
a skyscraper with millions of followers
and claim you're down infinite it comes
across as so delusional and out of touch
because i can almost guarantee you
dokuan has at least a million dollars
socked away somewhere i mean at minimum
he's not impoverished so there are
actually people who are down infinite
from luna but do kwan isn't one of them
and i don't want to get into the
specifics of what down infinite are but
you can just use your imagination when
people lose their life savings in
something like this what happens and i
bring all this up because it's important
to understand that part of the story of
tara luna's aftermath is dokwan's
attempt to paint himself as a victim of
it but part of this image rehabilitation
is with this interview itself with
coinage media because i think it's worth
being skeptical of them in part because
they're helped funded by dokwan himself
you see coinage media isn't just a
random company their parent company
trustless media is funded by dokuan in
fact the interviewer himself is the
co-founder of trustless media so
literally the guy who's supposed to be
holding dokwan's feet to the fire
his company is in part funded by the guy
he's interviewing so yeah many people
including myself felt that this was just
like you know a ridiculous puff piece
but not just because of the appearance
of bias but literally some of the
questions we're doing this interview now
because you want to talk about what
happened truthfully and transparently
i don't know if you're talking other
lawyers now and they're saying yo you
probably shouldn't do this
are they i mean are you serious how is
this a real question hey you're
obviously being so transparent and
truthful do your lawyers get mad at you
from how truthful you are like why isn't
it considered a possibility that dokwan
is lying to us and being opaque in fact
it gets even more ridiculous than that
because zach the interviewer even goes
so far as to suggest that maybe luna's
problem wasn't how big it got but rather
that it didn't get big enough but if you
were standing at the fiery scene of the
crash your first instinct probably
wouldn't be to say you know what the
hindenburg's problem was it wasn't big
enough but in the case of currencies
like tara that actually kind of was the
problem now obviously i think this is
nuts i'd be embarrassed to think this
let alone say it out loud like hey you
thought losing 40 billion dollars was
bad let's make it bigger next time we
didn't play it big enough we got to go
double or nothing and yet this is sort
of dokwan's defense for himself
according to him luna wasn't a ponzi
scheme and he's not like elizabeth
holmes he's just an idealist who bet big
on the future of currencies not that big
and i think i lost that's right guys he
lost he's just a victim like everyone
else he's down infinite or that's what
they want you to think and this is why i
think this arrest warrant is actually a
pretty big deal that alongside actually
arresting dokwan would go a long way to
debunk this defense to tell the world no
you can't just go start up billion
dollar ponzi schemes and then cry your
down infinite when it all comes crashing
down and so even though i can't put
dokuan on the wall of shame yet i do
look forward to the day where i can but
until that happens don't listen to
anyone promising you stable returns on
anything except me of course don't
forget to pump the stock
it's unruggable